yc is very very good at is making sure
you know what to focus on that you know
you focus on the right things
and that you only focus on the right
things and they're just amazing at
making you do that so it's obviously a
great experience for the company
[Music]
hey yogev thank you so much for being on
my show how are you
good good thank you for having me of
course so
incredible journey that i can't wait to
to dive into whether it's from
you know starting a company which you're
doing now to being a vp
product at a startup but before that
being
in a corporate like cisco and that whole
transition but even before that
uh drawing on your when you say your
first entrepreneurial experience to
commanding
one of the most prestigious computer
courses
in in the israel defense forces which i
think it's an incredible
take to to look at it from an
entrepreneurial perspective so i can't
wait to hear about that but before
everything else we have to talk a little
bit about survivor because i'm a
i'm a huge huge fan it's been a dream
since i'm like six years old to be on
survivor
why why do you love the show i love the
i love the game it's it's such a um you
know smart and fun game and basically
you throw um you know you throw
a bunch of people you know onto an
island they have to again it's not about
the
you know it's not about the um you know
these uh
competitions that they do it's about the
the social game
and how you get people to sort of follow
you and eventually you know
you essentially you know you know you
vote them out you do all these things
and eventually you need to
them to vote for you and how you handle
the social security it's just phenomenal
i think it's it's exactly it's it's such
an incredible game
because because like you're saying a lot
of people are enjoying the challenges
and the drama
it's not about that it's about this
whole idea of how do you go through a
journey and it's not and
and reaching the finals is not enough
right because then you have to have the
jury
come people that you blindsided and you
voted out coming in and
i don't want to give any spoilers to
people but i'll give a small one there
is a player on the on the american
series who i believe got to second place
twice or three times
over the 40 seasons so they brought this
player back because he was so
entertaining and he's very very
intelligent he runs i believe
a fuel company in the us but he only
managed to
get second place exactly for that reason
because he missed out on that other
whole aspect of the game and so we have
much more to talk about i'm actually now
watching the 37th season and i'm loving
it but
we'll have to catch up a little bit
later about that y'all take me back to
your journey
who are you way before you started a
cyber security company here in the
united states
sure so i guess very very quickly i
started my journey in the you know
israeli intelligence
forces
and basically i uh i joined you know i
was in the united 8200
um hopefully i cannot say that on the uh
the podcast
um and essentially what i've uh i've
been there for about six years
and i guess my last uh sort of the last
thing i did there
was running a course um
as you said it was one of the again it's
a course that i probably wouldn't have
gotten into as
you know as an 18 year old but i was
lucky enough to be
uh to be part of uh essentially uh
sort of starting it was the um i was
very involved since the first um
you know the first uh the first one and
got to be the commander the fifth
yeah i was a teacher in the first and
second one and then i uh i was um
commanding the fifth one so again was an
amazing experience
and what's very unique about this uh the
specific coin you can kind of dive
deeper into that
but what's unique is that it basically
involves a lot of different units within
the israel intelligence community
which is extremely unique for for any
course which again
poses a bunch of you know unique
challenges that you don't see in other
courses in terms of uh yeah
and again we can kind of go into there's
just so much sort of politics behind it
everybody wants to get the best people
at you know
that they come in but they don't
necessarily want to give the resources
because you know
this other unit needs to give the
resources right um now
just for context because a lot of people
that are watching this from outside of
israel may not realize but
you know this this specific course in
general the the army does a really great
job
at creating this filter of of of you
know they're starting out that they're
trying
they're getting anybody who might be
remotely interested in computer science
going through a series of tests
just as comprehensive if not more than
the college applications to stanford mit
or harvard it's really remarkable
the way that they're doing it at the end
you reach a cohort of just a few dozen
people out of thousands and it's sort of
it's like this childhood dream if before
people dreamt of being pilots and dreamt
of being you know on the elite combat
units
now a lot of people are dreaming about
getting to the course specific one that
you helped initiate and that you
commanded its
fifth iteration and so that's also why
people that are in the course they're so
sought after and to all the other units
because these are
some of the most brilliant minds talk to
me a little bit about you know being 23
getting thrown into this
responsibility of leading this course
and you and you're saying that this is
sort of like your first entrepreneurial
journey right
yes exactly well i guess i i it's
as i mentioned but part of this was the
fact that you're you have to you know
again here 23 years
you know years old you're not extremely
senior in terms of how you know you're
um um you know your rank
but then you have to deal with all these
extremely you know senior people
the um right you know the head of the
steering committee for the course
is the um um you know the
second command in unity 200 and you have
to deal with you know all these people
they're basically you know
10 levels you know higher than you are
from all these different units
and again you need and you need to make
sure that and one one thing is they sort
of give you this
you know you can do whatever you want
right you can do you can pretty much you
know they obviously on the technical
side
none of these people really have any
idea what you're doing you know
you know way better than they are but
also just in terms of you're sort of
thrown in this you know remote
location that's not in it within one of
the bases
and you can pretty much you know you
have all this freedom to to
to get people ready and do what you need
to do to get them ready for their uh
you know for their um for their service
um but the other thing is the resources
just getting the resources that you need
getting everything you know
pulling together uh the things that you
need from all these different units that
was
it was an amazing experience but it
taught me a lot about how to handle you
know large organizations how to handle
you know politics
how to work with you know people who are
not you know obviously don't report to
you but also
much more senior than you it was again
an amazing experience you know i
probably um
you know i think some of the gray hair
that i have now you know it's probably
just
that you know experience but it was it
was amazing and the one even more
amazing thing is that i
actually i uh met with my wife uh she
was actually running the
recruitment process for this course and
that's how we met
oh that's just beautiful and that's
wonderful but you know the course itself
it's not just another programming course
there's a lot of courses out there it's
not like taking a class at
mit and it's not like going to a summer
program to learn how to go this is a
very intensive period where you
as the commander of the course don't
just have the professional
responsibility for
the for the people going through it but
you're really responsible for their
livelihoods
over a course of a few months they're
relocated to another
area and he and they look at you as
the commander in charge and like you're
mentioning at 23
you're given responsibility that a lot
of people and that are 10 rings
above you that that's the responsibility
that they've been working for
for a long for a long time so so
definitely i totally appreciate
uh what what you're doing there and i
and i helped teach uh quite a bit
in different courses not the specific
one but it's
it's a remarkable experience y'all you
transition to to the united states you
do an mba at berkeley
you're joining uh you're you're at cisco
and you're transitioning
from there towards another startup talk
to me a little bit about about that
transition
or if you anyone even want to go before
to another start you worked out which
was acquired basis cisco
sure so yeah basically yeah this is
going uh since after i um you know left
the the military i um
i went to work for um a bunch of
startups and i was always
you know you have this sort of um i mean
now the startup
and cisco you interview a lot of people
and you see that some people you know
are more startup people and some people
love you know the bigger companies
and you know some people sort of you
know like both and it's a lot there's no
sort of right and wrong there it's
you know your personality what you like
doing and you know what one of the
things i always ask people is you know
why
they want to join us is you know why
startup and what i
part of it is just making sure that they
understand you know what that is
uh and part of it to make sure it's a
good fit and i
you know again maybe it was that
experience maybe it was just you know
friends i knew that startups was
probably kind of the right thing for me
i ended up working for a few startups
very early in my career i worked for
startup they got acquired by ibm
and that even sort of reinforced my sort
of thinking that a big you know a big
company is probably not for me
um even though
again i think ibm was very again there's
a lot of great things to say about ibm
but the the culture
you know wasn't a great fit for me at
the time and then i decided
to come here to the u.s and basically
get my mba berkeley
and that was to me a way to um
you know move to to to the bay area
where sort of everything happens it was
a really really great way to come in and
obviously somebody grew up in israel and
you know worked in israeli
again it was tech companies that you
know did most of the business in the us
but i didn't really have a strong u.s
network
and this was just a great way to come to
the bay area build a network here
and that was an amazing amazing
experience
and after doing that i worked at a
couple of startups here in the us
um the um
the second one i worked for was a
company called opendns in about a year
you know
in uh we got acquired by cisco
and again i remember you know getting
the uh the email from the ceo saying you
know
cisco's acquiring us it was i think i
was um i don't know why i woke up like
very early that morning and suddenly saw
the
email on my inbox and i remember
thinking you know i got it's going to be
the
sort of the ibm experience all over
again but it ended up being uh
being amazing um cisco's
very very good at acquiring companies i
think it's one of the companies that
acquired the most
most companies went through the most m a
um
ever and it was just a phenomenal
experience and it got me
sort of the view of what it's like to
work in this very very large
organization
and again i can talk a lot about sort of
the you know how well they sort of uh
merged us into the organization and how
uh our ceo ended up becoming
the head of uh you know an svp and the
gm for security at cisco
which again obviously is one thing that
you experienced which was very positive
and the mergers and acquisitions because
you know i
a lot of the people that i talked on the
show they've gone through these
different
mergers and acquisitions it sounds like
the majority of them aren't as
successful as
people hope them to be right and
obviously it's extremely difficult and
complicated process not just
you know technologically and
professionally but also in terms of the
culture because you're going from a
small startup
even you know even a hundred people is
tiny compared to thousands of people at
a large organization
when all of a sudden you have a new
identity so what was one thing that
you found really helpful in your
transition
yeah the one thing i think cisco did
very very well and i think ibm
so that's where they they missed um
cisco basically gave us the autonomy and
they didn't sort of come in and told us
you know this is what you need to do you
need to
change everything to be cisco they gave
us and again eventually it happened over
you know
a number of years but they sort of came
in and
nothing changed in the beginning we
still had our sort of stain reporting
structure we still had the autonomy that
we had
there were a lot of things i'm sure very
difficult for cisco to
still to agree to because they're sort
of very different than how they do
things
i'm sorry but they didn't they didn't
really change any of that they allowed
us to continue doing everything as
as we did and to some extent the their
approach was you know you guys have
built something very very successful you
guys are doing something amazing
we want to come in and learn from you
and they changed a lot of their you know
uh you know i
what i did there as i was running uh uh
the product management
organization for umbrella which was the
the leading product that we had
and they're basically saying you know we
want to learn from you how do you guys
run product
and i ended up getting a bunch of other
product groups reporting into me from
cisco
uh you know the scansave group and up
reporting into my organization the the
they basically said you know you guys
know how to do this
you guys are a very very successful
company which again was i think was a
very very smart way
of doing things right
so then you're transitioning from cisco
and and i'd love to make sure we have
enough time to also talk about
the current startup that you're running
because now you've transitioned after
being at a few startups being at a few
corporates and being
a commander in the idf you're now
starting your own company so tell me a
little bit about
angela security and and some of the
insights that you've gained throughout
the process of starting this company
sure so um i guess too too
a lot of my my what i did throughout my
career was getting sort of ready for
this i always knew i wanted to start my
own company
and a lot of what i did was sort of
geared through that even you know in my
mba i did my internship at a vc
firm just to sort of see what the other
side of the tables that it looks like
yeah and learn from that so after cisco
i went to be a vp
product at a series a startup at the
time series b startup now
uh to sort of see what it's like to be
an executive at a startup and get that
that experience as well um
and then um i was sort of uh
my time there was sort of cut short
because a friend of mine that i knew
from the
you know for the israeli intelligence
days i was actually a teacher at the uh
uh the course i was a commander of he
reached out to me
and he just finished his phd at stanford
uh
working with professor dan bonnet that
you might know of course
um so he uh he basically researched this
uh um
uh this uh something it's funny this it
was this huge huge security problem
uh that we both knew about in the
israeli military intelligence and to
sort of
say it in one sentence is that you can't
secure data and use it at the same time
every time data is being used it's
essentially not you know it's not being
secured
because it has to be in the clear in
memory um
and i i kind of ran into that problem
again and again throughout you know
going in the private sector as well so
open dns at cisco in a lot of places i
ran into how big that problem was
and he actually found a solution for
that problem during his phd with dan
bernay
so we ended up you know joining forces
and starting a company to actually solve
this problem
wow so so you you became a co-founder of
this company right
and and you joined so so what what
what's actually happening now where is
the where is the company in the life
cycle of a traditional startup
sure so uh this was so this was about
two and a half years ago we
the first thing we did was you know uh
start talking to as many you know
potential customers as
possible to understand if you know if we
we got the right problem
once we had enough information we
basically built a you know a
deck and started pitching this to
investors uh we ended up uh getting
uh uh both a seed round so we raised
three million dollar seed as well as gun
and two y combinator
amazing and we got and when we did that
it's fine it was the same week that we
got the you know the term sheet for the
investment
and the uh you know uh uh the call from
ic which was
uh we got a very so after
well it was a good week after you know
some very difficult you know a couple of
months it was a very good week
and yeah since then we grew the company
we raised
you know a significant series a and
we're now
basically a you know a company of 20
people um
tell me a little bit about y combinator
because that's something that you know
almost every startup
sees as like the glory of of programs to
go through to accelerate your
your growth what was that experience
like going through it
yeah yc is is amazing it's basically a
startup school
it's um you know
obviously it helped the company a lot
what yc is very very good at is making
sure you know
what to focus on that you know you focus
on the right things and
you only focus on the right things and
they're just amazing at making you do
that so it's obviously a great
experience for the company
for the company sorry but it's also an
amazing school for the
you know for me as an entrepreneur just
to you know to
to you know doing it is very very
different than seeing it from the
sidelines and again i've seen it from
the you know i was sort of part of it as
you know as an exec i was part of it as
an employee i was you know
i was looking at other from the outside
you know as uh
again doing the internship at a vc uh
but nothing sort of gets you you know
nothing
you know you know nothing helps you get
actually ready like and really
understanding what you're gonna you know
go through as an entrepreneur
uh and the one thing that kind of does
it the best is why i see they're
really doing a really really great job
and the last thing
the yc is doing is and i think you
probably heard this a lot this is not
becoming a cliche but
being an entrepreneur is an extremely
lonely job
there's really no one that you can you
know talk to the
again with your investors you have a
great relationship you can talk to them
about a lot of things
but again you need to be you need to be
very thoughtful about you know what do
you tell them what do you
you know and how you tell them things if
you have sort of you know very
uh sort of hexagensel you know you can't
really share
you know uh things like that and sort of
the same with your employees
right you want to shield them with a lot
of these sort of ups and downs that you
might be
you know that you might be experiencing
and what's nice about yc is that you get
this sort of cohort of other founders
that you can share all these things with
that is extremely extremely helpful
right no no 100 so what was what was
probably the most helpful
event with nyc was it the the network
that you were creating there wasn't the
goal setting
uh where i mean i'm guessing it was
primarily the founding team that took
part of it right not not necessarily the
rest of the employees as actively
no it was just me and my co-founder and
um this was basically we started yes
extremely early in the company's journey
again as we were getting the turn sheet
for you know the seed
uh we got into ic at the same week so it
was basically and it's yc is essentially
only for
uh for the founders and it was me and my
co-founder that went through this
um in terms of what we got from it
there's um
one is the yc network is is phenomenal
you know as you're part of the yc
network you can pretty much
it's like we emailed the founders of
airbnb and got a response back within
minutes like it's just this
amazing network of founders uh that is
just phenomenal
um and also yc continues
again they helped us sort of understand
you know what we need to focus on make
sure we're focused on it
you get these sort of by you know you
work with you know two partners
on a very very you know you know
throughout the program and they they
sort of help you
you know reach the milestone that you
need to reach but also they continue to
help you after you come out of yc
and you can you know you're still part
of the part of the network you can still
do office hours you can still talk to
people
you know whatever you want plus they
have these growth programs as well they
have something called the series a
program
that we actually didn't go through
actually um they're sort of lucky to get
uh to be preempted for our series a
but they do help companies in raising
their series a and getting ready to
raise their series eight
they also have a growth program that
help companies once they reach about 50
people
on you know growing the company since
then so yc keeps helping you
you know throughout the life cycle of
the company and obviously they've seen
probably more
you know startups than anyone else right
so they can do a really good job at
helping you there
and that's just phenomenal yeah best of
luck with the startup it sounds
incredible
and and i just love you know this this
journey that you
that you went on and and you really got
to taste so many different parts of the
tech ecosystem and
the fact you're saying that a lot of
these experiences were geared towards
preparing you for this
incredible journey that you're on now i
think that's just really
that's just a really awesome way of
looking at it and and the way that
you're talking about
you know your experience as the
commander of of that course in the idf
i think it i it totally resonates and i
think it's part of the magic of startup
nation part of the magic that also
eric schmidt talks about a lot and the
book obviously startup nation talks
about that it's this innovation through
necessity
and you know when you think about
commanding a course and the idea if you
don't necessarily think about
you know you think about the
professional side of it and the
mentorship but but you're presenting
this whole other side of
you had to innovate your network to
innovate politics in order to make sure
that this works
hey all before we leave i want to thank
you for being so generous of your time
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
sure so uh will you give me a minute
before we started to uh
you know to to think um so yeah
i think the the three words um i would
use are um
one is is passionate um
number two is curious and i really
believe in the sort of student always
mentality i think you're always you know
you can always get better you can always
you know learn more and i
i love
why is that explain that a little bit
more i
i think one of the best things
especially evil regardless obviously as
a manager but but definitely as an
entrepreneur
the one thing important thing you build
is not really the product it's the
company
and a huge piece of building a company
is the culture that you build and one of
the things i'm focusing on
the most is how do i build the right
culture how do they build a culture that
you know i would want to be a part of
and again working for a lot of startups
i think i've seen sort of better
cultures and sort of worst cultures
and it got me thinking a lot about what
culture i want to build and i want
to have a place where people you know
enjoy you know enjoy being a part of
that you know and
to me it's all about i think like
actually
it's a little story which i think is
sort of the best way to to think about
this
um i i was sort of lucky to meet eric
yuan the founder of zoom
uh on a couple of occasions uh instead
of small group settings
and he talks about the culture that he's
building and you see all these companies
with like you know the company you know
values like these seven things they put
on the wall and it's like super
you know i think nobody nobody reads it
nobody remembers it
he said and we sort of adopted it that
are you know at anjuna as well he's
saying the one
you know uh company value that they have
is care
they say it's you know caring about the
employees caring about the customers
caring about you know
your investors it's the one thing and
every time i sort of go back decision to
to me
to make i kind of go back to that and
think about that and i think that's an
extremely important
important piece of uh you know building
a company
wonderful yeah thank you very much to
nagabat this was just a this is just
wonderful
best of luck thank you